this is called Mud larking searching for
historical artifacts washed up by the
River Thames now it's a popular hobby
but in centuries gone by Paul londoners
would have been digging for something to
sell
the blue is a mineral it's called
vivianite Alessio caconi has found
objects from thousands of years ago this
shoe is more like 300 years old He
restored it himself the person probably
was walking a bit on a wonky way maybe
his leg were not too straight and in
fact he's very squished on the inner
side
these days historical items found here
should be reported to the Museum of
London but plenty of mudlocks get to
keep their Treasures you need to have a
permit to Mud lock but so many people
are doing it now that the port of London
Authority has stopped issuing new ones
books about this Hobby and posts on
social media have helped to inspire a
new wave of enthusiasts we've gone from
about 200 foreshore permits issued about
four or five years ago to 5 000 now and
that's a vast increase and what we're
doing is protecting the integrity and
the archeology of the foreshore the
Thames foreshore has become an
international attraction for Scavenging
but for one Canadian family the permit
Port has ruined their mudlocking plans
we've invested
thousands of dollars
um to to go on this trip which can't be
amended because we can't get refunds
we're always curious about you know
where you came from and how how your
ancestors lived and and what was their
life like and what you know what kind of
things did they use if you already have
accreditation you can continue muddy
searches for pieces from the past just
make sure not to get caught out by the
tide Becky Cottrell Sky News the Thames
foreshore